this morning on the dish the Houston
eatery Lucille's and its chef Chris
Williams one year ago Williams was
forced to close his southern style
restaurant during its busiest month
after the flooding rains of Hurricane
harvey lucile's has weathered the storm
and is having its best year since
opening back in 2012 the inspiration for
the restaurant goes back three
generations into the family history of
its owner and chef tucked inside the
kitchen of his restaurant chef Chris
Williams prepares the dishes he's
created from scratch having tasted each
and every ingredient but shockingly
Williams prefers his customers be the
first to taste the final product I make
it and send it out look at the guests
reactions I don't know this is my thing
okay
even with his take on the classic pork
and beans oh my gosh that has flavor
pretty good you never know what might
meat on his dish chili biscuits
topped off in cheese and dark chocolate
braised duck confit served atop sautéed
collard greens with a parsnip puree
where did you learn to mix so many
different flavors I was fortunate enough
for my experiences this is all my travel
and I've done it always makes its way to
the plate on a whim Williams spent 2002
at La Cordon Bleu in Austin but says he
never considered making a career in the
kitchen until he backpacked through
Europe cooking was like mine my hustles
my passionate hustle when you say it was
your hustle you mean it was like the way
you'd get earned a quick buck right
didn't matter where I was in Europe if I
didn't speak the language or anything I
could burn so in kitchens it doesn't
matter what language you speak because
we all speak the same when it comes down
after a stint in DC Williams moved home
to Houston to open Lucille's the
namesake of his restaurant his great
grandmother
Lucille Bishop Smith she was a matriarch
to your family right but also she was
just like that that pioneer and
trendsetter and just fearless with what
she was doing a chef a culinary educator
and entrepreneur starting in the 1930s
Smith had her own general store
developed curriculum at Prairie View
college and ran a camp for girls this is
really a shrine to Lucille yeah we call
it a reliquary in his private dining
room upstairs
Williams created a place for all the
relics he found researching his family
this is Lucille's recipe book that's the
treasure chest filled with mid 20th
century favorites candy called desserts
cookies Lucille fed everyone from
heavyweight champ Joe Lewis to Martin
Luther King jr. in this letter President
Lyndon Johnson thanked Lucille for
shipping fruit cakes to local servicemen
fighting in Vietnam but perhaps she was
best known for her own special invention
served in first class cabins on American
Airlines the original instant quick
biscuit so we make the original recipe
the slow three-hour method but in that
industrial time people were looking for
something convenient and quick yeah she
came up with the way to make an instant
and then 30 minutes later you have your
hot rolls does his hot biscuit and his
chili biscuit live up to Lucille's okay
here we go I made them I served them for
seven years
this is getting closer and closer than
this there it's right there now
William's father and mother Connie and
Patricia Lucille's granddaughter used to
work for her at the all-girls camp
Waldemar in Central Texas it must be
something for you to look at him and say
wow he's carrying on the family
tradition here much so obviously
grandmother could have lived to see this
she would have been so proud there's
this discovery now of southern American
cuisine and African American cuisine all
over the globe I mean you love good food
wherever you are you know being an
African American food of Southern
cuisine
this is Americana like that everything
that's you know original about American
cuisine and you know where we came from
it came off the backs of slaves at
southern soul food is the base of the
American food scene now this is now
being recognized for what it truly is
the best food I ever find anywhere ever
goes the food of the poor people I find
that to be the most creative food out
there it's not fancy beautiful fake just
honest and I think I find that beautiful
Lucille's has faithfully served
Houston's museum district since 2012 but
was forced to close its doors during
Hurricane Harvey I came in the middle of
our busiest month and stopped business
for almost a full month his kitchen help
feed Harvey's first responders I know a
lot of people had a
and some really tough experiences and we
want to contribute to do it we paid so
we did never really like made it so part
of the culture of the restaurant which
is what my great-grandmother is all
about William says he remembers visiting
with Lucille during her final years a 7
year old boy helping to feed the
great-grandmother whose days of feeding
others had long past
so if you could have this meal with
anybody past and present who would that
be and why you'd probably be my
great-grandmother yeah not a doubt let
her see how I size up to her and she
would think can you imagine those silly
biscuits are not right I need to let
them rise with another 30 minutes where
you put them in the oven yeah I could I
can see you're just being a
perfectionist